sorry tough guys it's part two of a day
in the life of the stay-at-home husband
when i say check your misogyny at the
door i mean it
it's the weekend so you know i gotta let
my queen sleep in so i make her some
pancakes she likes them with chocolate
chippies in them after i flip the script
on these gender norms she wakes up to a
hot plate of pancakes on sundays we
strip the sheets and then i load the
dishwasher next i borrow my wife's
credit card and i go get some groceries
i check those eggs check out make my way
home and put the groceries away the
fridge organized with all her favorite
drinks and snacks and then i take the
trash out to where the men go don't
strain yourself queen stay-at-home
husband not even a stay-at-home dad
this is called being a useless deadbeat
that's what that's called
[Music]
you know what i really call it i call it
your wife is cheating on you
the fact is that she doesn't respect you
and marriages cannot survive intact
absolutely cannot cannot survive if the
wife does not respect the husband